Dr. Zakir, is it allowed for one to eat
and drink
even when the mu'adhin announces the
call to prayer for Fajr? Is it allowed
to eat and drink? Some people, I'm not
sure if whether it's correct or not, but
some people believe that you can eat and
drink all the way up to the Fajr adhan
and beyond. I'm aware that there are
some Muslims who believe that you can
eat and drink until the Fajr adhan ends.
And there are some people who when they
can hear
various adhan of different mosques from
their house,
they wait till they hear the end of the
last adhan. So, if they can hear five,
six adhan, they wait till the last adhan
ends, till that time they eat and drink.
In fact, this is not proved from any of
the hadith of the prophet. And anyone
who innovates a new thing
in the deen,
it has to be rejected. It's mentioned in
the hadith of Sahih Bukhari, volume
number three, hadith number 2697, that
anyone who innovates a new thing in the
deen, it has to be rejected.
In fact, it's clearly mentioned in the
Quran in Surah Baqarah, chapter number
two, verse number 187, that eat and
drink until
the white thread of dawn becomes
distinct to you from the black thread.
That means the moment dawn breaks,
moment you hear the adhan, you have to
stop eating. And as I quoted earlier,
the hadith of Sahih Bukhari, volume
number three, book of fasting, hadith
number 1918 and hadith number 1919,
where Hadhrat Aisha, may Allah be
pleased with her, she said, "When you
hear the adhan of Bilal, may Allah be
pleased with him, continue eating and
drinking until you hear the adhan of Ibn
Umm Maktum.
For when he gives the adhan,
it is the time for Fajr, that dawn
breaks up. That means the moment you
hear the adhan, you stop eating.
The moment you hear the adhan, you stop
eating. But, there is a concession given
by our beloved Prophet, may Allah be
pleased with him. It's mentioned in a
sahih hadith of
Sunan Abu Dawud volume number two in the
book of fasting hadith number 2343
where the beloved prophet said
that when you hear the adhan
and if you have drinking vessel in your
hand you are allowed to satisfy yourself
from that vessel.
That means our beloved prophet has given
a concession that while you're eating or
drinking something is in your hand you
can
complete it.
But that doesn't mean that if you have a
big sandwich in your hand that you
complete it. If you have a bite left of
that sandwich in your hand and then you
finish it it's fine. Or when you're
drinking a glass of water and there is
something left in it you can have it.
That doesn't mean you can go out of your
way and touch your hand and pick up
another glass of water and keep on
having have a big burger or a sandwich
or keep on eating for a few minutes
after the adhan started. And it's a
misconception that you can eat till the
end of the adhan. There's no hadith
saying that.
Because you start the adhan the moment
the Fajr prayer's time starts. A moment
it's the break of dawn the adhan has to
be given. The moment you hear the adhan
you have to stop eating.